Céline 21 ans est la porte-parole des
gilets jaunes ici à Vesoul depuis le
début de la mobilisation elle est là
tous les jours aujourd'hui avec les
autres gilets elle a appris la nouvelle
vie sur une manif ou non on n'a jamais
entendu parler ou on dit que c'est les
gilets jaunes qu'on voté pour eux alors
que nous on a on n'a jamais entendu ça
on a rien été consultante
moi je bénisse à 8 gars qui ont fini au
gouvernement puis accoucher des 10000
euros par mois un choix partagé par les
autres gilets jaunes qui se sentent
oubliés voire même mépriser
pas à ça parce que en aucun moment nous
a demandé notre avis et
ces 8 personnes on voudrait bien
connaître leur périphérie pourtant
depuis 10 jours tout est organisé pour
tenir ici du café pour se réchauffer de
la nourriture pour ce restaurer Céline a
souhaité depuis le début défendre cette
ruralité des jeunes des anciens trop
souvent oubliés depuis Paris les jeunes
n'ont plus d'espoir ça c'est clair et
net mais les vieux eux ils sont anéantis
c'est les retraités tout ça c'est
aberrant ce qui se passe c'est et c'est
là dessus qu'on se rejoint un combat une
histoire pour cette jeune mère de trois
enfants qui dans la vie de tous les
jours et commercial depuis toute petite
il y avait cette injustice là mon père
devait travailler le week-end à faire
des heures avant tout finir parce que on
pouvait pas finir les fins de mois donc
c'est vrai que depuis tout petit je
comprenais pas pourquoi ceux qui
bossaient qui bossaient même très dur ne
pouvaient pas vivre derrière alors de
retour à ce rond-point ici à Vesoul même
si la déception d'un choix que personne
ne comprend est là Céline continue de
prendre le temps d'écouter les gilets
leurs histoires de vie leurs difficultés
qui sont au bout du rouleau c'est des
ambulanciers qui sont payés à 80% alors
qu'ils font un travail de dingue c'est
des retraités on en parle même pas
ah oui non c'est des personnes qui
vivent dans des caravanes alors que la
neige va arriver des gilets jaunes de
Haute-Saône qui ne se sentent pas
représentés mais qui dès demain vont
continuer leur combat